a very specific character from the DC
Universe that you excited to see an
arrow I always bring it whenever I could
I've had that question quite a few times
today in the last couple weeks and just
pertaining to all the movies that are
being made and stuff like that in the
comic book world it's also taking a side
from the TV shows because we had the
Suicide Squad and these things inside of
it Argus we were going really heavily
into that for a minute and then I mean
something must have come down from DC or
some some higher-up above that said no
you must ceased and desist because we're
going to make it into a movie and we
can't have anybody spoil that idea and
we did get to see that little like
pigtail and Argus uniform and the little
treat of a Harlequin and then it just
got ripped away so if we could actually
have Harlequin on the show that'd be
amazing but it's never going to happen
on the subject of Harlequin obviously
there's been a lot of debate lately
about the alleged
under-representation of female heroes in
the Marvel Universe and some of these Z
franchises I'm curious for you guys how
you feel about that if you have any
thoughts on that and how shows like
arrow are going about redressing that
balance um that's actually a really good
question because one thing that makes me
so honored to be on this show is being
able to do a justification of this
characters arc as a female and as an
empowered woman I mean she just gets
beaten down by by everybody in her life
whether it be the males or the females
just everybody in her life has just been
lying to her untrustworthy all that and
she honed into something inside of that
like herself and it's becoming what she
is becoming and it's very very amazing
to be able to represent that and it's I
think a lot of the girls on our show
have been pulling that stuff out really
hard like Katie Cassidy's character has
gone through so much and now just come
out the other end like a very strong
woman and I have very high hopes for the
future for for women being empowered in
television and in movies I think that
Harlequin could be a great one as is
like crazy sexy super villain but take
it away from just you know her being
sexy and actually just being strong and
powerful and that's usually what should
be pushed out there far more than
pumping up the breasts and showing her
ass like let's actually show her
or what she gives physically capable of
following on from that question
you saw the backlash against Mad Max
fury road from a lot of people saying it
was too feminist I was still got a long
way to go
I've haven't seen it yet but that made
me so mad dear that I mean I I guess I
have no I've never seen it I don't have
any opinion on it yet other than the
fact that what is wrong with some guys
out there saying that like I just don't
understand how how did the conversation
all of a sudden just get reversed like
what's now there's there's male
activists all of a sudden like okay it's
fine it's great congratulations
you